hi I'm a player unknown or Brendan green
I'm creative director on pub G and I'm
here today with wires pub gtex port Bry
rules oh one pub gee hef why am I so fat
of the game I'm bad at the game I don't
know why I'm just better players out
there but listen keep playing and find
bushes and love it that's my advice I
denied E I'm guessing why are vehicles
the weight of paper are they flipped way
too easily no if you travel at 120
kilometres over fields vehicles do tend
to flip you know I'm quite proud of our
vehicle physics I think they run quite
well yes
collision visions physics aren't what
they they should be but really you know
I add the way that I see some of you
drive vehicles of course they're going
to flip mr. n RT oh it's an essay so
when will the other maps get increased
loose you know so this is the problem
with so like if everyone learns input
or everyone lands in school
there's gonna be someone that gets the
weapons and someone who doesn't you know
my recommendation like with the way I
play myself is get out of you know those
really heavily populated areas and get
out to more you know sparsely populated
areas and spend that first initial time
looting dropping up with and hot
dropping is fun but more than likely
you're probably gonna get mowed down by
someone who finds the gun before you so
you know listen will we're always about
balancing loot and in the future we want
to run some more balanced passes on the
loot so you never know what might change
but yeah I'd spend that initial time not
looking for action and looking for
weapons neural or I breathe tea it's a
good thing to breathe I've peaked in pub
G when are we getting points for cool
tricks event oh listen we want to flesh
out that out game and give you more
achievements and stuff like this so you
never know what might happen as a
feature you might get those extra points
is ever us ask spunky so let's get to
the point yet his pub G corn to ps4
simple question for a simple answer I
wish it was simple no listen right now
we're focusing on PC and getting Xbox at
one point oh that's that's really all I
can say yo what's good with this every
game my character goes headless love
Xbox game preview who's going to be bugs
well we get them fixed before 1.0 can we
get his indicators like I just want a
general sense of where the hole in the
back of my
came from please we all want this no no
y'all don't want this
no listen hidden Decatur's are fine but
we've really spent a long time getting
our sound system to a state that you can
tell where you're being shot from if you
know how to use the sound system hit
indicators I feel it just makes a little
bit rkd and we already offer you lots of
tools as to know where you're getting
shot from not party for me I got a
question our test server BP gonna merge
with the regular server if not what was
the point of giving my for testing the
hint is in the name hey pop G instead of
adding new stuff can we take a minute to
focus on fixing the old stuff and making
it smooth yes but why can't we do both
the engineers that fix the game and make
it smooth are different to those that
create new content you know we have to
give our to something to do and a new
content is one of these things it's
motor bilk red zone is still a thing why
a country to be thinking that you're all
bad players no listen the red zone will
always be be tuned it serves a purpose
in that it provides audio cover and a
distraction sometimes but you know we're
always looking at ways to improve it and
make it kind of a part of gameplay
rather than an annoyance to players and
now that we've got doctor disrespect and
shroud skins and pub G well can we
expect some team skins soon maybe listen
we we always want to give support to
professional players and teams in the
game so you never know what we might do
in the future I wonder how many bullets
have been deflected by the frying-pan
now I want death by Pam versus saved by
pan ratio we have that data maybe but
there's so much data it takes so much
time to run through all of it
maybe someday viva la Conrad hello
player unknown I bet you yet this
question I laughed but I thought I'd ask
is there a plan to add offline bot mode
we get asked this question quite a lot
listen we'd love to add a sort of an
offline shooting range type thing but we
have some technical issues preventing us
from doing that at the moment let's see
what we do in the future but I can't say
yes or no right now
Scooby's 86 world Luce does not spawn is
this only for the event mode this needs
to be implemented in normal wargames as
well yes listen you know war games are
and custom games in general are still
being iterated on and custom servers and
event service they still need some work
so stuff like this will we get
bugs are dead someday don't worry so
when is trading coming back listen we
put up some posts on our steam community
about this there are some issues with
some from some trading practices let's
say that so we want to work to get those
ironed out so until then you know we
have to put some restrictions in place
so why is falling rain no more so
rain we want to bring them back
but we just need to make them a little
bit better there was some performance
issues there was some rendering issues
that we need to fix so you know we're
not saying not coming back but we want
to make them either look better before
we think about it just an aka speed can
we get an ak-47 you in an ar-15 SP or
added even the beretta storm or a desert
eagle that would be freaking awesome yes
it would we're gonna be adding new
weapons of course coming this year not
in Lansing anything yet but you know
there should be some things that will
make you happy so what it means San Hawk
so fun chicken that's what it means
please do something about jump shooters
it's not a fair strategy look are aiming
mechanics and stuff are you know they
really do reward people that aim down
the sights I'm guessing but you know
this jump shooters if you can jump and
shoot if you can manage to hit someone
you know I think it's a good shot I'm
not quite sure what the problem with
jump shooting is Pope G as we're in
early access on xbox why don't we get at
least try aim assist the thing about
game previews we want to work with the
community and see what the best way to
to do em assist if we ever end up adding
it you know this is why we're in game
preview is is working with you guys and
getting this feedback so we're not
saying an assist won't get added but
right now we we we have more pressing
things to fix first why do they not make
challenges for player to be motivated
we're working on this you know the whole
out game and achievement system we want
to give it an overhaul and you know
change it up and make it more
interesting one only Kingsley asks how
do I change the red dot style in the
settings menu
why do slowly moving vehicles give so
much damage are you going to fix that
yes of course we want to fix all things
to do with their vehicles and collision
it just takes some time but we'll get
there so feels to us why I have that
comes off the others well they
I've been added to the PC version and we
were hoping to bring them to to the Xbox
version as well but again this is why
we're in game preview because we want to
upgrade the game over the coming months
well Tricia asks how about a
post-apocalyptic map now we've had too
many post-apocalyptic everything so you
know Amit our maps are meant to be
abandoned anyway and we want to do some
more interesting terrains but I just
feel post-apocalyptic has been done to
death at this stage geo get money TV why
is there a gun range of PC mobile but
not on PC where it began because we face
different challenges to doing it on
mobile and doing on PC the mobile
developers have done an amazing job
getting a really playable version on on
a mobile we just you know we have
different priorities internally for the
PC version so it just takes some time
what about a night operations map our
flashlights and slow the pace of the
game down for the map that would be cool
having flashlights and the crates have
night vision slow the zone down to offer
for stealth that's not a bad idea we've
talked internally about what night maps
as well and even some of the the
settings we've tested internally look
great but you know no no confirmation
yet but night maps are something we
thought thought about Clara mom why
don't you open up the skins to mothers
and let can we make and sell some we'd
love to do that of course but you know
these bring their own challenges about
you know troll skins and so for that so
we'd love the way that that valve and
daughter do it with with their skin
system so maybe someday but not right
now
golden frying pan plan I don't know soon
Shaqiri I guess can we place it as not
the option to be able to see what your
character looks like what skins you
don't own I need to know how I would
look with these new skins I that's not a
high priority right now
maybe someday query 27 how did you make
a game so fun yet so frustrating so
casual yet so competitive I just made a
game I wanted to play I guess Sansa
SOCOM where did you come up with the
name idea and it's a picture of the
battle royale movie really like quite
obviously that's where I came up with
the name mikonos asks why hasn't pub she
made a frying pan only server yet that
would be a fun time and with our custom
games which will be opening up to more
people this year maybe you
can't have just frying pan only servers
let's see sceptic Falcon a sceptic I
like sceptic one question do you sleep
sometimes maybe on planes when
travelling but yeah I get some sleep
Luke McKay who's down for some chicken
dinners always always down for chicken
dinners thanks all for tuning in to
Wired pub G tech support giving you some
health bar some support for your
questions and listen we're always
working to make the game better don't
lose faith yet thanks so much and see
you next time
[Music]